hello everyone and welcome to a most
exciting game from round five of the
2019 sinful cup its
Dingley rain versus onigiri we haven't
covered a lot of games from the same
felt cup as it's been a very slow event
up until this point but now it became a
bit more exciting we're gonna show a bit
a few more games from this round and
then we're gonna check out the standings
for the first time so without further
ado ding with the white pieces opens
with d4 now with Knight to f6 c4 with
East 6 sorry about that
Knight to f3 and we go into the the
Queens gambit declined as usual with
Knight the c3 and Bishop to b4 we have
data goes in defense Bishop to g5 and
now h6 pushing the bishop back with
Bishop captures Queen captures enter now
Queen to a4 check forcing Knight to c6
otherwise you're gonna lose the bishop
so Knight to c6 with III and now comes
castles and here rook the c1 so this is
all been played before nothing out of
the ordinary here just your standard
error goes in theory now we've looked to
d8 by Geary and now Bishop to e2 where's
the question Bishop to e2 D captures on
c4 Bishop captures on c4 as usual you
wait for white to develop the bishop
only then do you capture on c4 so you
make wise waste a tempo and here there
are is a game where Bishop d7 was played
there is also a game where if I was
played but the move get replaced it's a
new move in the position and as a rush
of captures on c3 we have a completely
new position in the game with B captures
on c3 and now Bishop to d7 preparing
some discoveries with the knight so
being prepares for it with Bishop to e2
now there are no good discoveries and
Bishop three two guards from Knight to
e5 now yes your queen is under attack
but you don't have any worries for
example you can just move the Queen back
Queen to a5 or anywhere and if Knight
captures then the bishop is ready to
recapture you don't have to ruin your
bone structure so after Bishop d2 we
have E 5 by Geary and now it's a bit
different now actually Knight captures
on d4 is a threat because the pawn
covers the d4 square so here if you even
if you tried the d5 still Knight the d4
is annoying after Queen to be won
you can trade the wooden ice cap for
sunny - and after Queen captures you get
E for sorry about that
efore and after the knight moves to d4
or here now Queen g5 threatens the G to
pawn bishop h3 is coming if you castle
it's a very very annoying position to
play for white black would be much
better here so here being retreats with
Queen to c2 and now Bishop to f5
Gary prepares to push for Queen to be to
attacking the b7 pawn and now comes eve
for just attacking that night Knight d2
and now Knight to a5 defending the b7
pawn but also making room for the c5
thrust with castles biding you don't
want to leave your King in the center of
the board for too long and finally c5
being attacks sorry Aguirre attacks
dings strong center with rook F to d1
developing the final rook and Giri does
the same we have rook a to c8 and now
Knight to f1 are preparing to remain
over the night with Bishop to g6 what
ideas of maybe doing a nice rook lift
but also just preparing to move the
Queen and start pushing your F pawn we
have knife to g3 and now comes Queen to
g5 preparing f5 and the dingos Queen to
be one the e4 pawn is now under attack
by the Queen and by the knight so f5
defending it and here it's not all that
easy for ding to improve on the position
he plays D captures on c5 he prepares
the rook to d4 he wants the double rooks
on the D file whereas for example the
engine gives Queen to b5 it seems like a
nice idea you attack the knight you kind
of forced B 6 and then Quint a6 you
threatened to infiltrate the position
Queen e7 defending and this is one such
position you can play the engine
considers this an improvement but pink
is not an agent he considers something
else an improvement so D captures on c5
but it's it's not not a natural move
it's it's a
well it's a it's an unprincipled move
you don't want to capture away from the
center and leave your leave your C pawn
isolated but if you can't find a way how
to improve it you you sometimes have to
play it and this is what ding does we
have DK actress on c5 rook captures and
c5 and now look the d4 dings idea is now
he wants to double works on the D file
and if he doesn't like that he will have
the capture and then ding will improve
his pawn structure so dink says ok no
problem I'm just gonna double rooks on
the C file the story theory says that
Bishop to f7 putting pressure on the a2
pawn we have rook C to D 1 now
controlling the D file and a Giri does
the same on the C file we have Group D
to c8 and now Bishop to b5 a deacon
defense the c3 pawn via a tactic for
example if rook captures Bishop d7 I
just attacks the rook and the f5 pawn
and the f5 point is a much well is a
more important point than the c3 pawn
after the rook moves for example route
c4 just gonna capture here and after
let's say characters and captures your
efore point is attacked four times now
and you're gonna lose it and white will
just be much better here
so after there should be five we have g6
Gary prepares for this idea defends the
f5 pawn and the now comes Knight to e2
now defending the c3 pawn no problems
there Queen to f6 preparing to
centralize the Queen with Queen to e5
and now comes the Bishop a4 ding is
preparing Bishop to b3 to fix this pawn
structure we have Queen to e5 by Gary
and the Bishop to b3 by Dean and now you
have to either capture on b3 which is
why doing plated Bishop to b3 or you
could go for Knight to c4 which is a
tricky line and what lucky just doesn't
really have a watch to look for here for
example is Bishop captures on c4 Bishop
characters now you can play Ruby a check
and after captures captures you're gonna
go King to f7
now comes Queen captures on b7 with
check rook c7 walks but now Ruby d7
check captures captures and now after
Queen d7 you can choose either to trade
Queens and go into the same game being
up upon but it's a bishop against the
night and play on both sides
the board or you could go somewhere
Queen d2 to guard a pawn for example
like this your Queen d2 and then you
played this endgame so this is a black
the best bet if he goes nice to see for
Gary decides to go knife capture son b3
this fixes dings pawn structure but well
there's a lot of play still on the board
we have Luke 5 to c7 preventing rook to
d7 and here just c4 Dean starts pushing
his C pawn with a6 preparing b5 and now
comes Knight to f4 now things night is
coming to d5 and there it's gonna be a
very strong night with b5 and Knight to
d5 point being that if you capture the
night rook captures on b5 is just wrong
because for example I have to remove the
Queen Queen e7 you get the rook to d6
you go after the g6 pawn and now how do
you defend it it's not easy for example
if you play King h7 just c5 and you're
gonna play before you have a nice nice
past C pawn whereas black cannot capture
it because you lose the Queen so after
Knight to d5 with rook to c6 getting
broke out of the way and also from there
the rook will help help out with the
defense of the position but now against
e5 you still can't capture it because if
you capture than just the Knight b6
attacks the rook after you move the rook
Knight d7 forks the rook and the Queen
so you lose material here Giri just
continues with a 5 and now we have B for
a capture some before queen capture some
before and now rook the BH defending the
b5 pawn we have nice the b6 threatening
Knight to d7 again with the same idea
you wanna fork the rook in the Queen and
now Bishop to e6 this prevents the loss
of material but dink has other plans for
the position with Knight d7 now for King
the Queen and the rook Bishop has the
capture with Bishop characters and now
rook to d5 first trying to get the Queen
away from the from attacking the pawn
and only then will ding recapture and d7
so we have Queen to e7 and only now rook
captures on b7 with Queen captures on c5
and now Queen to b3 check
queen bee to with with the threat of
mate is also possible but being prefers
Queen to b3 trip Quinta c4 and only now
Queen Derby to now Giri has to block
with Queen to c3 there's checkmate the
threat of checkmate their queen to c3
and now Quinta a to check again you have
to block this with the Roku or the Queen
doesn't matter why it's replies the same
we have looked to see for biding and the
now comes well
twin to a 7 is possible just threatening
some background ideas but first the
nearest position is so great that he can
even waste ways to move with the g3
creating an escape route for his King
even though he doesn't need it
we've looked the c8 now putting more
pressure on the C file preparing to push
the beep on although it's it's hard to
say why why this rook is better on c8
but the ding just continues with his
plan with rook wanted e6 he decided this
is the better way to go than Queen to a7
that's why he freed the g2 Square for
his King now the threat is real
characters on g6 with King to f8 there's
no way to defend it enter now comes rook
captures on g6 and b4 giri now starts
pushing his passed pawn with rook
captures on h6 and now well black is
just lost a giri played one more move
and hereafter G captures on f4 onigiri
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to do here
the threat is just he had he had a free
D F pawn so the Queen will be guarding
the H square to prevent rook 2h8 mate
but whatever you hear you could give one
check let's see quincy one check King G
2 and now Queen c3 yes you defend the
mating square but white can just play
Queen d2 and now you don't have a move
if you capture a rookie Jade is just
mate if you try and keep an eye on this
diagonal for example Queen a1 you're
gonna get Luke this exchange 826 share
King goes here and Queen to f7 this is
not made so of course Giri knows this so
in this position unmoved 47 he resigned
the game and a very nice victory for
Dean we ran in round five of the 2019
single cup so that's the game I do hope
you enjoyed it
like I said I will show at least one
more game I will probably show two but
at least one more from round five as a
la a lot has happened in round five and
then we're gonna check out the standings
for the first time uh yeah like I said I
do hope you enjoyed it as usual you can
check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
sink fold Cup continue in the capablanca
saga and of course as always checking up
on your lovely suggestions so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day